vous avez vu mes yeux pourquoi les
fermes ton quand on éternue
l'éternuement est un mécanisme qui
permet d'évacuer les impuretés qui se
glisse dans nos narines les grains de
pollen par exemple pour les empêcher
d'atteindre nos poumons
irrité par ces intrus de petits cils qui
tapissent notre kobe nasale envoie un
message au cerveau et qui déclenche la
tempête les muscles notre cage
thoracique se contracte l'air y compris
mais il remonte jusqu'au nez et dans le
canal lacrymal qui débouche au coin de
l'oeil tout se passe comme si une
poussière s'y était glissé les paupières
se referme par réflexe au passage l'air
qui est expulsé peut atteindre 50
kilomètres par heure
pas mal pour une capsule de des confiné
aller anodin et n'oubliez pas nous
sommes confinés
mais en restant lien à this way merci la
petite caméra
si vous avez aimé cette capsule 2d
confiné n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce
bleus gens réalisent une nouvelle chaque
jour alors pour ne pas les rater
abonnez-vous et activer la cloche
merci à toutes et à tous et à demain